in just five seconds the Earth would
look completely different
without oxygen you can say goodbye to
the Hoover Dam the pantheon Dome and
anything else made of concrete these
structures would instantly collapse
oxygen acts as a special binding agent
to concrete without it concrete is just
dust
speaking of buildings any untreated
metal would instantly be fused together
this is because there's a layer of
oxidation on metals that prevents them
from welding together without that layer
Metals would instantly bind to each
other
if you happen to be relaxing at the
beach at the time expect a severe
sunburn the ozone layer our protection
against the Sun's UV rays is made of
oxygen take away the oxygen and the
Earth would become extremely dangerous
there would be nothing protecting us
from the Sun's UV rays